regardez l'événement que vous êtes en
train de créer en devenant Coco Chanel
l'oiseau paradis elle en couverture de
ma
avec 8 à 10 pages
FIA romada aujourd'hui
bientôt dans Vogue bientôt dans glamour
avec une interview par Serge Julie qui
sort de la politique c'est assez amusant
comment on est venu vous voir pour vous
proposer notre channel Coco Chanel et de
faire ce que vous allez faire et qu'il a
décidé vous vous avez demandé conseil à
des gens autour de vous alors ça s'est
passé à peu près il y a un an
les personnes de chez Chanel ont
contacté mon agent de cinéma et puis et
puis je pense que je sais pas il y a eu
des coups de fil entre pendant pas mal
de moi
j'en sais rien je pense qu'ils ont fait
des tests on fait des on fait des choses
comme ça dans ces moments-là et
peut-être que les tests étaient
favorables j'en sais rien ou peut-être
que tout bêtement je leur plaisait
et puis donc ça a pris pas mal de temps
et puis un beau jour on est arrivé à
déjeuner tous ensemble avec Jean-Paul
avec avec toute l'équipe de chez Chanel
et puis et puis j'étais séduite j'ai dit
oui tout de suite en général vous
décidez toute seule oui
avec une équipe qui sont des gens qui
font un peu partie complètement partie
de ma famille donc on a tendance à en
discuter ensemble mais la décision c'est
forcément moi qui la prend
qu'est-ce que c'était pour vous Coco
Chanel ou en tout cas Chanel avant avant
la rencontre avec eux avant la rencontre
c'était quelque chose
pour moi ça va rien avoir avec une
marque de vêtements ou de ou de parfum
je pensais à un mythe pour moi c'est
aussi fort que Marilyn ou James Dean et
Chanel c'est quelque chose il y a même
si un jour c'est plus la mode de porter
du Channel ça sera toujours aussi
important et en tout cas on repensera ce
qui s'était passé que ça existait et
depuis longtemps oui pourquoi parce que
quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir est en
très fan de Marilyn Monroe j'avais une
photo d'elle avec une bouteille de 5 à
la main que je trouvais magnifique
comme elle d'un parfum aujourd'hui il y
a beaucoup de curiosité autour de vous
Vanessa c'est vrai est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment qu'on vous aime et est-ce
que ça a toujours été comme ça
toujours été quoi depuis je chante
depuis que
vous êtes né sans doute avec votre
famille et vos parents vos amis mais
depuis que vous chantez depuis quand
vous avez pour la première fois vous
vous posez vraiment la question de
savoir si j'ai l'impression qu'on aime
depuis que je chante j'ai pas mal de
problèmes comment elle au début et
j'avais vraiment franchement pas
l'impression qu'on m'aimait et
aujourd'hui je pense que ça va mieux
j'en sais rien il y a des choses qui se
tempèrent et qui se calme au bout d'un
certain temps et puis et puis j'ai pas
le succès un succès aussi rapide que le
mien ça je pense que les gens ont du mal
à l'accepter donc au bout de quelques
années ça s'efface un peu dans l'esprit
des gens et puis je deviens quelque
chose de normal quoi
[Musique]
un certain nombre de gens quand vous
lisez elle a un charme perversée étrange
est-ce que vous croyez que c'est
simplement le physique
[Musique]
ça serait triste quoi mais
j'en sais rien peut-être
pendant un moment j'ai pensé que les
gens étaient intrigués par moi parce que
j'étais adolescente et qu'on est très
loin de lui à cet âge-là aujourd'hui
j'ai bientôt 19 ans et peut-être que
maintenant que je suis plus obligé plus
plaire du tout j'en sais rien je sais
pas
on dit elle a 18 ans 19 ans quand elle
va être adulte mais adulte plus
longtemps depuis longtemps
on a tendance à dire que le 18 de la
part des 18 ans ça change rien et
pourtant le jour j'ai eu 18 ans tout a
commencé tous les excusez-moi mais les
emmerdements des adultes j'ai les ai
reçus et je sais je sais ce que c'est
maintenant c'est c'est bizarre mais dans
ma tête je pense pas être adulte et
chaque fois vous remettez le compteur à
zéro vous recommencez la vie
moi j'aime ça j'adore ça j'aime d'abord
j'aime pas quand les choses sont trop
simples j'aime bien me battre et j'aime
bien avoir la sensation que rien de
toute façon ne va être facile et qu'on
va pas m'aider donc partir un point zéro
c'est le meilleur moyen je pense alors
on va revenir au 30 secondes de pub je
suis d'accord avec ce qui dit que c'est
un chef-d'oeuvre en pub de Jean-Paul
Goude le trapèze c'est vous hein
[Musique]
et donc ça s'est très bien passé c'est à
dire que malgré les peurs le vertige
peut-être les sueurs Vanessa ne veut pas
de doublure
a demandé quelque chose de complètement
hallucinant peut-être que je me serais
fait doubler mais là ça n'était pas
vraiment compliqué donc je sais pas
pourquoi je l'aurais pas fait vous
recommencerez vous continuez à faire du
trapèze on voit la vie comme ça d'en
haut avec ce balancement qui était
facile de légèreté c'est formidable
j'entendais j'avais entendu les trapèzes
dire que le meilleur l'endroit le mieux
où ils étaient c'était là-haut et c'est
vrai quoi c'est une sens tellement on a
tellement l'impression d'être libre
d'abord je suis pas première chose si on
a envie de se lâcher personne peut vous
empêcher on le fait donc c'est vraiment
la liberté là
quelques temps je disais vous disiez je
voudrais être quelqu'un de bien je dis
ça
c'est important d'être quelqu'un de bien
je voulais savoir ce que ce que c'était
quelqu'un de bien pour Vanessa Paradis
définition quelqu'un de simple de je
pense d'intègre avec lui-même donc
intégré avec les autres peut-être on
peut on peut passer une grande partie de
sa vie sans trop tricher d'après vous
tricher mentir
je crois pas que ça soit une bonne
solution parce qu'un jour ou l'autre on
le découvre qu'on a triché vaut mieux
être vaut mieux être vrai même si ça
plaît pas toujours et puis en tout cas
la sincérité ça fait toujours je pense
c'est le mensonge qu'on découvre quand
on arrive à l'âge adulte
c'est ouais on découvre des choses qu'on
pensait pas exister on se dit non c'est
pas possible c'est trop gros et puis si
ça existe
est-ce que vous vous souciez ce qu'il y
a dans la tête qui imagine les gens qui
vous regardent
je sais pas un coup en un coup d'œil on
le voit en regardant les yeux des gens
on voit tout de suite s'ils ont envie de
vous cracher dessus ou s'ils ont envie
de vous donner des baisers ou ça se voit
tout de suite mais je sais pas on me
regarde beaucoup alors en général
j'essaie de pas regarder les relations
avec les gens sont plus compliquées
maintenant
je les trouve plus simple qu'avant plus
simple que quand j'avais 14 ans
et qui je suis et tout ça quoi donc
c'est peut-être plus facile mais c'était
c'était pas facile quand j'avais 14 ans
c'était une très dur à cause de la
gloire qui est née tout de suite ou oui
c'est tellement rapide et puis il faut
un temps pour s'adapter à ça quoi je
veux dire le succès ça a quelque chose
de merveilleux c'est merveilleux enfin
je parle pas du succès de faire de la
musique quoi c'est merveilleux mais il y
a pas de choses autour qui sont pas
forcément merveilleuses et il faut vivre
avec
[Musique]